we're going to begin with the weather
it's not so good a massive storm
drenching the Gulf Coast just one of
three potentially dangerous weather
systems were following for you this
morning
hurricane Umberto is a powerful category
3 storm that's quickly approaching
Bermuda
tropical storm Jerry is expected to
strengthen into a hurricane later this
week and meanwhile flash flood watches
are in effect from southeastern Texas up
through Louisiana as tropical depression
imelda pushes inland here's a look at
the water off Galveston this morning as
it gets pounded by lightning and heavy
surf imelda has already dumped 3 to 5
inches of rain in Houston and as much as
9 inches in some parts of the area
Jeff bear Adelie is here with the latest
forecast Jeff good morning what can we
expect from these three storms yeah so
Tony imelda is gonna drop a lot of rain
it's not gonna be Harvey we should say
that however some places will pick up
two feet plus of rainfall take a look at
the radar as you can see the
counterclockwise spin the heaviest rain
has been on the barrier island around
places like Galveston and Freeport is we
turn this 3d for you what you're gonna
see some big towers kind of boiling up
over the very warm Gulf of Mexico waters
big thunderstorms they're kind of riding
over the same area rainfall rates to
three inches per hour some places have
already seen over a foot of rain as you
can see and as long as the band doesn't
move will continue to pile up this rain
dangerous flash flooding is likely
especially on the south end and the
eastern side of the storm as we take it
through the day you'll notice the storm
moves towards the north very slowly so
it's not moving very fast heaviest bands
are on the south side and the east side
really for the next 24 hours you may get
a break in Houston and Galveston but I
think stuff will redevelop to the south
again during the day tomorrow total
rainfall is likely to be widespread a
foot some places over two feet of rain
especially in isolated areas east of
Houston so watch out folks stay off the
roads if you see impassable water areas
just do not try to drive through it
alright Jeff thank you very much